[Music]
this
is star talk i'm neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist
and we're here with a cosmic queries
edition
we love me some cosmic queries ain't
that right chuck yes sir
absolutely that's because you you
collect all the cosmic queries and i
don't know if you
bring them to stump our guests or what
you know do you filter them or they just
randomly
plucked from the uh they are actually
taken by a randomizer so
i can't i cannot take credit
for pulling them which means that uh
please don't send me your questions
personally
all right so chuck today's cosmic
queries we're going to
explore the perseverance rover of nasa
in which uh this month we're recording
this in february
uh lands in february and it was launched
you know nine months ago ten months ago
and so but i don't have particular
expert i know about a little bit
something about mars
but not specifically about perseverance
and
i think you don't know about either
right so absolutely
i i know about curiosity and i don't
know
oh and i'm not talking about a lander
all right uh so we've got our friend at
nasa at nasa headquarters
jim green jim welcome back to stark talk
thank you so much neil and chuck
always a pleasure always a pleasure to
see you
and i was looking at i was looking at
your full bio and
i'd forgotten i mean i remember but i
forgot that you used to be head of
planetary science for nasa
but now you're ahead of like all
astrophysics
wow well that's badass yeah i'm just the
chief scientist
so oh shoot sheep sure not just not just
astrophysic
science scientists right that's defying
all categories
yes that's true so that's that's badass
i'm just saying
that's yeah i've enjoyed that i mean
it's really all about
uh advising the administrator on uh
new science activities and and wonderful
things that are going on in the agency
and the fact that you came to it as a
planetary guy
means you have good sort of geology
sense as well
so and if you did planets it meant you
had some good astronomy in there
so you've got enough of a diverse
background to serve the scientific
portfolio
of nasa is that a fair statement that is
that is uh you know i've got a
undergraduate degree in astronomy uh you
know
in fact i just finished my first
exoplanet paper
you know i've uh you know i've been
involved in a lot of planetary
uh uh magnetospheres and and done some
solar physics so i've touched on
heliophysics
and uh of course one of my favorite
planets is the earth
that's a good choice one of my favorites
my one of my favorite too chuck your
favorite
uh mine is kepler 22 at this particular
point
he's showing off no i'm not that's from
that's from a sci-fi movie
i would i wouldn't know oh oh oh oh the
series
the sci-fi series the firefight series
yes that that uh
they're called raised by wolves so
that's that's the only reason i said
that
is that the ridley scott series that is
correct sir yes and it is oh man i gotta
catch up with you on that one but it's a
habitable exoplanet it's uh is is one of
the main characters in the movie
in the uh in the series and kepler was a
nasa
telescope memory serves fabulous
absolutely
really pushed uh the boundaries of what
we know about
um the developing uh planets around
other stars
i just love it when nasa discoveries
fuse into pop culture and then it just
becomes
part of how people think about the world
around us so this is a cosmic queries
but before we
get to questions that people have sent
our way
on perseverance just remind us why is
this yet another rover
to mars i mean how many damn rovers are
we going to send
what did you not learn last time that
you're going to pick up this time
well of course with curiosity we learned
that
mars was really quite diverse than what
it is today
in its past we explored the past of mars
we found out that
mars four billion years ago had an
enormous amount of water
and the conditions were such that it
could have been habitable
we really didn't know that and now we're
going to push the next
step on that and that is to go to an
area
and look for ancient life and that's
what perseverance is going to do wow
oh okay so each rover mission
stands on the shoulders of the previous
mission in the questions that it gets to
ask
absolutely that's the way it works
nice and and you have to send a whole
new vehicle to do that
well it turns out of course uh
spirit and opportunity looked so much
different than what curiosity does
but at the end of uh uh
curiosity's uh building we had
many spare parts and so i think we had
like 200 million dollars worth of spare
parts left over from curiosity
like an ikea of furniture yeah
well no that's if you don't know how to
build it you have spare parts wait wait
jim no but i'm telling you you're making
a soul
a single object a single thing called
curiosity
and you're telling me they're leftover
parts this isn't some heath kit
that you bought from radio shack this is
this
so what do you mean you have leftover
parts well we have
duplicate parts so
when
guys does it fit here nice [ __ ]
any suggestions guys on this what
for everybody i'm sorry go on no problem
for every one of our missions
we want to be able indeed
to have spare parts around or extra
parts
such that if there's a failure we can
immediately bring in the new part and
not worry about ordering your supplies
so it's a real critical real critical
of thinking it's a necessary redundancy
it's a necessary uh for building the
mission
right wow okay you got me there okay
i'll let you slide on that one but
that's the last time i'm letting you
and tell me you want you going up there
with a helicopter so what's up with that
so one of the elements one of the
important elements of this mission
is actually enabling the future
and to do that we're going to push the
envelope on our understanding
of getting around on mars and a
helicopter is really
a unique idea to do that you know so
this is what we call a technology
demonstration you know we're going to be
able to
hopefully uh drop this helicopter off
the belly pan
of the of the rover drive away let it
unfurl
and then order it to start flying and
we'll do a variety of tests
and it will go up and then come down and
then we'll go up and translate
and then come down you know and after
translate means it it will just
go horizontally when you say translate
its position
okay so chuck you know what this would
look like if a cartoonist drew this
the martians would be watching this and
the rover drops the helicopter out of
its belly and it thinks it was pregnant
right gave birth we're babysitting
all of a sudden
what kind of helicopter if i'm not
mistaken mars has a different
atmosphere than earth so wouldn't we
have to have a different helicopter
indeed indeed so it's drone-like in many
ways
you know it has a small body but it but
it has
very long uh of
uh you know rotors and they're about a
meter you know about a yardstick long
okay and there's two of them and they
counter rotate
and that enables this small
uh helicopter which is uh you know
a box like a cubesat you know it's a
it's about uh
10 or 12 centimeters by uh 10 or 12
centimeters in a cube
that enables this then to be lofted and
fly
uh great distances you know 50 60 70
meters
before it sets down again so but the
real problem is
the martian atmosphere is really thin so
you have to compensate by having bigger
rotors is that that's your solution
that's right and the counter rotation
helps the stability
so that we don't need a rotor on the
tail
so it's a design feature now if you can
imagine this working
then the next set of missions could
indeed
leverage this concept and lay down
additional helicopters to then survey
massive regions up close
on the surface of mars so it's a what
we'd call
a an enabling technology demonstration
for future missions
beautiful cool beautiful oh and one last
thing
is this is landing on mars the same way
uh curiosity did
it does it does so it's this it looks
very
rube goldbergian you know with a drug
shoot and retro rocket
and this and and who came up with that
well the jpl engineers are some really
fantastic
jet propulsion labs propulsion lab
engineers
fantastic people that had a long
experience in landing craft on mars
and the whole concept evolved you know
we
we started with uh pathfinder and uh
uh pathfinder is a platform for which
the sojourner rover
rode on we landed that and and then the
sojourner rover came off the platform
and then we had
spirit and well wait you didn't land
that one you bounced that one if i
remember we bounced
it we bounced it you bounced it with
some airbags we did
we did and we used that same concept
you know spirit and opportunity and and
you know they bounced of course and then
when we deflated the bags
the rover sits upright on a platform and
then drives
i just loved how i loved how low-tech it
was
for something to do something high-tech
afterwards
yeah there's something really genius
about using a hoppity hop
to drown to to land a sophisticated
piece of space machinery that's
incredible
well it you know for spirit and
opportunity
we believe it bounced perhaps as much as
30 times
before it actually settled down on the
surface
where we could deflate the bags and then
move it off the platform
so imagine this now now we're going to
build a bigger rover
okay spirit and opportunity are less
than 200 kilograms
okay and now we're gonna do one
metric ton okay
2 000 kilogram a thousand kilograms a
thousand kilograms
five times what spirit and opportunity
were okay
so the concept is well we start out with
a platform can we put it on a platform
and then
figure out how to land the platform the
problem was
the center of gravity was too high
so if it's on the platform it's going to
flip over
so now we can't land it on you don't
want that
don't want that i can tell that right
now okay so then the next
evolution in thinking is okay let's put
the platform
on top of the rover all right
and that gives it retro rockets all the
way down to the surface and you land it
then the problem is
how do you get the platform off the
rover
so then the unique idea is
let's hover it and lower
the rover down to the surface while the
platform is
hovering at about 20 meters
and when you see it like with a joist or
something right some kind of joystick
that's called the sky crane and
when you decrease sky yeah the sky cream
and when you think about that that's a
process we do here on earth with
helicopters
every day dropping off cargo picking
them up
going through that process so why
couldn't we engineer
that for a mars mission excellent
excellent so it's so it's brilliant to
know i mean engineers
this they live for this right yeah they
know what has worked in one application
and they modify it add to it no that's
i love it i love it so so chuck what
kind of questions you have
hey let's jump into it um
we'll start with leslie murray by the
way let me just say
uh jim people love
nasa like you guys
you guys need to take a little bit more
advantage
of the public goodwill that you uh enjoy
and get more money because people love
not only domestically but
internationally internationally as well
yeah
i mean there's people are so excited
here it's great yeah
anyway this is leslie murray and she
says jim green is this from patreon is
this a patreon
um leslie does not say oh actually
patreon yes sir thank you thank you very
much okay uh
these are patreon uh these are patreon
folk first
and uh as we say um we certainly enjoy
anyone who supports us on patreon
uh because we certainly enjoy uh money
so thank you um
i'm just i'm just being honest but
please forgive truck
he's still in training for in this house
listen i'm sorry i don't know how to
diplomatically say
thank you for giving us money it's very
hard for me to figure out
the proper way to say that yeah we'll
put you in
it we'll debrief you after the show okay
all right so all right what's up murray
uh patreon she says this
um jim green very excited to ask you
if you could have added just one more
interesting instrument to the rover
what would have what would it have been
like
i love that question i like and this she
says this like
every rover i'm sure this one was on a
weight loss plan
um well
i i have to tell you of course i was
head of planetary we
landed the curiosity that worked great
in and we began the concept of well
we needed we need bring back samples we
need to go and get the
rock samples that tell the history of
mars
and we need to bring them back and and
that that was the thrust of what
perseverance is going to do
and and how we were able to convince
nasa and the administration and then
congress to support this next move
so the instrument i wanted that i dearly
would have loved to have on it
i actually got it on
and that is an audio instrument
you know we've never landed on mars and
listened you know to
to the wind to what we can hear
and i now have two microphones uh on
on uh nice okay when you send audio
instrument
i know you meant microphone i'm at a
microphone i gotta tell you jim when you
said audio instrument
i was like what a waste of money you
sent a radio
to mars who why not put some cup holders
on it
who is listening who is listening to
whatever
commercial but no yeah exactly but no
the microphone
that's super cool okay so it adds
another dimension to our senses
we think of and feel about mars very
good oh my god
so when when this thing lands
and you deploy these microphones you're
we're we're going to be able to like go
to nasa uh
and and listen to what mars actually
sounds like
yes but even i guess it does storms and
things
even before we land we're going to turn
on one of the microphones
during the landing process oh my god
so we will hear what's going on inside
the capsule
as it hits the top of the atmosphere and
and the in huge temperature variation
just outside the heat shield
is going on as it's burning away the
material
on the on the heat shield and then the
chute
and then the sky crane all the way down
to the surface so
we turn it on right away okay now
since i've been zooming for 11 months
now i just want to make sure
do you have a mute button because
that can be problematic
[Laughter]
well um not that i'm aware of we do have
an on and off button
but um our hope is that everything will
survive intact and we'll be able
to use this engineering microphone
as it moves and the reason why that's so
important
what we found out with curiosity is as
it went over some rough terrain
the rocks were literally breaking the
aluminum
uh wheels you know poking through them
and so the engineering microphone is
designed to hear the creaking and the
cracking
and the moving and then that's an
element of the diagnostic
of the environment that we're in that
helps manage the rover and its assets to
keep it going
wow this is that that old story you take
your car into the shop and they ask you
well what's wrong with it and he said
well it's making the sound and
it goes like like
[Laughter]
there's the acoustic diagnostics in this
case we'll be able to play it
wow play it back uh just before we go to
break
um is the carbon dioxide atmosphere
such that frequencies will come across
differently in the sound um than what
will you have to shift it to like an
earth spectrum of
audio so we'll actually know what's
going on or we're just going to enjoy
um the higher or lower frequencies
commensurate with the well it'll be
lower
you know so turn up your bass uh you
know the the
atmosphere is heavier and you know
carbon co2 is uh heavier than oxygen and
nitrogen
and of course as we talked about it's a
much thinner atmosphere
so sounds that we would normally hear as
high pitch will be
very low you know it will be
base level and of course once we have
that data
we can change the range and enhance it
but i think it will be absolutely
fascinating to hear the real sounds of
mars
based on the the atmospheric composition
and the pressure
i was just going to say i think it'd be
more fascinating if you turn the
microphone on and you heard
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
tuning in to radio mars
well you know the hope is at night
at night wait wait wait it'll be
and now this is the martian version of
barry white
and then it's a frequency so low you
can't even hear the frequency
well you know at night we hope to hear
you know crickets
right or or something else
that would be cool that would you would
that would that would be scary
that would also change the entire
existence of our life here
martian crickets and crickets every
martian comedian's worst nightmare
my marching crickets
yeah if they're crickets after you tell
a joke you're on the wrong planet all
right
this is where crickets are really
important
so we take a quick break we're gonna
come back with
jim green chief scientist of nasa we're
talking about the perseverance rover on
star talk
we're back star talk cosmic queries mars
perseverance
edition i got chief scientist james
green
jim just welcome back to star talk it's
always great to know you're there for us
and uh and nasa has a huge social media
presence
i think your biggest handle there is
just at nasa right yeah
you got a squillion followers on at nasa
not only in in twitter but in especially
in instagram where you're knocking it
out of the park every time you put out
something
on the universe just congratulations to
to all of you
for creating those images and the social
media team for
for navigating them in ways that the
public can embrace
not only does nasa have their handles
social media handles but you
have a podcast with the greatest name
ever gravity assist
very cool what kind of guests do you
have on there oh neil
i have some of the fabulous working
scientists that are uncovering some of
the secrets of the universe
that you know really won't end up in
textbooks for
many years and it's so chuck he's
compiling the secrets of the universe
without telling anybody i am
okay that's what that is so i just ended
my fourth season
and the podcast is called gravity assist
can't lose with that okay good good good
luck with that good luck with that
this really to me shows that the public
is
very inquisitive i mean it's a it's an
element of our nature
to to really try to see
and uncover new phenomena
in new regions and take new views of of
the universe we live in
not to mention seek out new life and new
civilizations
and he left out that part yeah thanks
for continuing
to boldly go yeah where no human has
gone before
there you go all right
thanks chuck for completing the the yeah
you have to finish that out otherwise
you can't leave it dangling
all right what else you got chuck nathan
nathan hui says will there be
any live footage capturing the
perseverance's exciting landing and
maneuvers
and if so how will it be recorded and
how can we watch
thank you and good luck nathan
well you know it's kind of cool because
how do you you know where how
like yeah how do you record the thing
that you're
in unless you have some something else
recording it
yeah camera out on a boom or something
so what are you doing there right so
what
what of course happens is uh once we
land
uh we actually uh will begin to unfurl a
variety of things
so so here is um a model of the rover
and one of the first things that will
come up
will be our major camera
and this is as tall as a human is in
fact if i stood next to
uh perseverance i would i would i would
just be
looking into the camera lenses that are
on the mast
this gives us a wonderful opportunity to
view
the area as a human would but okay but
that's after you've landed that's after
you've landed but you've got nothing for
us
yeah you guys got nothing for us while
you're plunging through the atmosphere
we do we have a whole series of cameras
in
many different locations and so what we
will see
is we'll see the the the parachute
deploy
we'll see that we'll also see
the heat shield drop away in the ground
below us come up rapidly and then we'll
see
uh that view of the ground as we land it
with the sky print
cool will there be any sky crane footage
so of the
lander itself making its small descent
from the sky crane down to the
surface well we'll only know that's
happening
because we will uh hear
and see the ground come up as we lower
the rover
and we will also hear the retro rockets
that are firing
holding this the the platform the sky
crane
above the surface hovering okay but you
don't have a camera in the sky crane
looking down
as the rover descends that would be kind
of cool yeah it would be okay so next
mission
next mission chuck said chuck told you
here and now that that's on your next
mission
sweet oh one other thing of course
mars is many many light minutes away
yeah
so if we watch this what we think of as
live is really delayed by how much
well uh light travels you know an
enormous speed but it's still gonna take
uh close to eight to ten minutes
uh before we actually get the signal
uh and then we're going to damn so mars
is like a hundred million miles away
damn when this is happening it's a waste
it's a ways away
so the whole thing could have just
exploded and
busted up on landing and then we'll just
sit there and think everything is fine
for another eight minutes
indeed we won't we won't have we won't
have any knowledge of that
and so that's you know what you're
bringing up is a perfect point
everything has to work the first time
perfectly and we can't joystick it we
can't make any mods
and when it hits the top of the
atmosphere it is on
its own
very cool all right again right shout
out to the engineers who made that work
okay chuck give me some more here we go
uh neil chuck jim
my name is violetta i am 12 and a half
years old
and i have a very important twelve and a
half make sure you get that half in
there
absolutely so important right i've i am
still using
uh halves and quarters a teenager
almost a teenager 12 and a half i think
yeah
does anybody say 22 and a half i i'm not
sure
um what is your advice for the next
generation of
nasa scientists in regards to space
exploration what should we
dream of study and dream of now
if we expect to one day be the first
generation
that travels to mars
this is a 12 and a half year old asking
this so
that's really uh that's really cool well
it's really all about following your
passion
get involved in an element whether it's
engineering or some aspect of the
science
and just immerse yourself
enjoy it and let it lead you
to these different opportunities
whether it's an opportunity to work in a
company or
industry or laboratory that are involved
in building instruments
uh or or in one of the nasa centers you
know
and even getting involved in in building
space vehicles for humans
nasa collaborates with companies like
lockheed martin and boeing and
and other places to build spacecraft so
nasa doesn't build all their own
spacecraft
space probes correct right for
perseverance
and of course the ingenuine ingenuity
helicopter
we built those nasa did build both of
those
but it required instruments to be built
by
many different groups and universities
okay so what that means is
what we think of as nasa's budget
goes not only to nasa but to innovative
corporate companies engineering
companies that also do work in the
service of nasa
so they would get a paycheck that's not
signed by nasa but signed by their own
company
but ultimately it came from all of us
supporting that enterprise
indeed did i capture that yes you did
just to summarize what you're saying
jim is that it's one thing to say
oh they're doing this now let me train
so i can do that when i'm their age
that's one thing another thing is
i am so passionate about this thing
whatever it is
maybe it's my passion that will create
an opportunity that doesn't even exist
there today yes indeed
that is really the case to dream big
and then follow your passion follow your
dream
and then maybe other people will beat a
path to the door of your passion
and then you'll be the leader the next
leader of the science at nasa
that's right and have a badass business
card
[Laughter]
all right chuck keep it coming all right
here we go this is toby
sonnenberg who says hey neil
and jim how can nasa predict which
rocks may hold signs of an ancient
biochemistry if that biochemistry
is completely alien to us
uh i think yeah that that there may be
some assumptions being made in that
question but still
yeah no no no excellent assumptions so
jim if we're looking for life as we know
it are you going to miss
life as we don't we don't wow indeed
we don't want to just look for life as
we know it we need to be open-minded
and that requires getting the samples
back
the ancient history of mars is in that
rock record
and we're gonna uh you know create a
core
in fact here's what the cores look like
with a drill
so here's here's a core so it's a core
is like basically a cylinder
that you extract from the object and
then you have the full record
of layering that's right so somewhere in
in this time history life
may have arisen on mars all right
so now we have to bring this back
because we can't in
in any way interrogate this sample
on the surface of mars where were you in
the night of july 10th
and so you can't use the word
interrogate in front of black people
of that word
sorry not your fault not your fault i'm
just saying oh god that's just funny
okay oh gosh uh
you're interrogating your core sample
yes to do that
analysis we then want to put the core
in a sleeve like this
and then we'll lay it on the ground for
later pick up by another mission
and so we are out we are actually
planning now to pick up the sticks to
pick up the cores yeah
and then brilliant we're building a mars
ascent vehicle
to bring it back now it's the analysis
of the rock record
is forever if we get it back here on
earth
we can interrogate it we can we can
create
theories on hey we might see different
types of life than we expected
the record is here to continue that
discussion
and then eventually prove your theories
or disprove them
and and tell us about what mars could
have
could have uh harbored life in its past
so at the risk of stating the obvious
the geologists
can see back in time simply because
the stratification of geologic forms and
structures
preserves that and that is their analog
to what we do in astrophysics whereas we
look out in space we look back in time
yes because light takes time to reach us
so the farther away we look
we can see a thousand years into the
past a million
even a billion so i've always felt
geologists were our kindred souls
one looked at looks down the other looks
up in this exercise of decoding the
history
yeah so in the same analogy you know
astrophysicists
look at different frequencies of light
all right
because it tells them different things
when we bring this rock record back
we're going to use different instruments
to determine the mineralogy in other
words how material is
put together the composition of
what those nodes are in the mineralogy
the the state of the matter in terms of
uh you know what we call isotopes
and so now we can interrogate all those
different dimensions
because we have the rock record right
here at home so it's a bit of
so it's geochemistry geochemistry all in
yeah
so neil uh do astrophysicists ever
interrogate the light
that they find from when they're when
they're studying
one day one day we'll do an explainer
video
of all stuff we extract from light yeah
and it is a stupefying
amount of information it's amazing
contained within light yeah yeah yeah
well we'll do that chuck remind me no
use holding out on us
x-rays we know what you did okay
we know where you've been more than the
gamma rays you got to watch out for
exactly they're right over your shoulder
there
all right now give me another question
maybe we can squeeze one in before we
uh go to the break okay okay this is rob
carter he says hello i was wondering
what protection this rover
has from the mars fine dust
after the mars digger issues last month
this is somebody who's following along
that's for sure
uh is there a way of stopping the dust
from
gathering on the solar panels and if so
what's another major issue that the
rover will have to overcome
and we will only learn about that after
the commercial break
see what i did there all right can't
wait
stay tuned when we come back more cosmic
queries on star talk
all about perseverance on mars
we're back star talk cosmic queries
perseverance speaking of perseverance i
have something completely unrelated to
the topic of today
this morning took my 92 year old mom to
get her covet vaccine
yeah that's amazing up in harlem
hospital so
so there it is 92 and she's ready she's
ready for
more she's ready to rock and roll now
she's ready to rock and roll she's like
neal where are we going
where are we going now let's go we're
gonna get out of that show
i said ma i ain't been i don't get my
shot yet okay my category hasn't come up
yet
okay so when we laughed left
off rob carter had asked about the
protection
of the mars rover from the very fine
dust of mars
citing the digger issues of last month
uh
we might i don't know what that is and
then he says is there a way of stopping
uh the solar panels from gathering dust
as well and what other issues
have you foreseen that the rover will
overcome so those are all of his
questions kind of
boom so indeed here's a model
of perseverance looks just like
curiosity
and it has its own power system it's
using
radio isotope power it's using plutonium
238 and plutonium-238 is really hot
you put this against a thermal couple
which
creates a voltage difference which
charges a battery
and then it's like having your iphone
plugged in the wall all the time
all your instruments work so this can be
coated with dust we don't care because
we've brought
our own power supply and you work at
night as well
it doesn't matter if the sun is up or
down okay
but what's really exciting uh from the
question um i i think your listener is
interested in what's happening
also with insight which has solar panels
and the solar panels of course will
accumulate dust but one
really exciting thing that this insight
the name of the the name of the lander
on mars
is steam is the dust is being blown off
and it's not from it's not from uh you
know the
twisters that it has seen spirit and
opportunity does
but it's from the same phenomena it's
just not
visible so the atmosphere has these
vortices that indeed blow
the the dust away and we don't need a
dust devil to do it
okay well okay but how about the how
about the machinery
and the moving parts you know you can't
bring anything to the beach
here on earth because sand might get in
it and that ruins
ever it ruins everything you assume you
don't want to ride a bicycle on the sand
so won't the dust get inside the the
moving parts and isn't that bad
well that's a good point but indeed
the the rover is really sealed well
and in the compartments uh that
it has uh like curiosity would be meant
to
acquire material and then shut off
so um uh we don't see that as a problem
you know it's like keeping your your
windows up and your
car doors shut all right and and you can
operate well
inside even during snow storms so jim
remind me
what insight was well insight is a
lander that landed on mars
in november 2018 and deployed
a seismic system that allows us to hear
mars quakes
and it's measured over 500 of them since
then
and this is telling us a lot about the
inside of mars
and the fact that we now believe that
mars
at least partial part of the core is
liquid
we didn't know that before so jim if
we're measuring the atmosphere
the surface looking for life places
where there is water
and the inside of mars what
what are you actually planning
what's the long-term objective here
well we need to know how active mars is
let's say you go there build a structure
and then there's a mars quake that tears
it down so it's really all about
understanding how to live and work on
that planetary surface but from a
planetary
perspective we want to know how it's put
together
so that we can become martian overlords
that's the goal here
i'm starting to get the feeling that you
scientists are planning a trip without
the rest of us
i'm just saying it's a little
frightening
chuck keep going all right give it to go
let's go to we'll keep him moving we'll
go to woody
woody says this hey what's the top speed
on this would you have a last name
nope that's it does he have a last name
i think he's the cowboy from the pixar
movies
i don't know i i'm serious he just says
okay so what's the question he said
what's the top speed on this bad boy
that's it all right so let me
demonstrate it
okay so if this is the rover this is the
top speed
all right so your hand is slowly because
some people will only be listening to
this
fitness center so so your hands are
going like one
mile an hour inches per second
he's moving with the alacrity of a
galapagos turtle right now that's
basically that's what that's what it
looks like
okay no so if they're turtles on mars
they'll look and say what's wrong with
you
you got wheels like the race we would
love that race
six wheels to a martian turtle come on
man
rover versus galapagos turtus that'll be
good
good all right all right um let's go to
mikey taylor
from illinois he says or is it illinois
or is it illinois
illinois isn't it french
is it wait is it illinois french so that
this the trailing continent is silent in
france
illinois okay illinois anyway he says uh
villanois okay well maybe it's not
french i don't know but if it is you
leave off the s
and if it is france then all the people
in illinois
actually shop at target okay
exactly so
mikey taylor says how do rovers
uh most sensitive instruments
survive entry and is there
a chance that they can be damaged
i like that yeah it's that's a really
important question because
we now know that we have to build them
to be rugged
so understanding that right off the bat
is critical in developing
the right capability to survive what we
call
the vibrations and the loads that occur
by moving quickly you know so there's
the launch sequence
and the shaking of the rocket and and
moving it
high g uh and then there's the landing
you know where we're going to go from
the top of the atmosphere
to the surface in seven minutes under
going through various loads so once you
know that you have to design it
and build it that way and then test it
right so so you have a bunch of shock
absorbers for everything built into the
structure of the system right otherwise
that the that
uh the accelerations will be felt
directly
by the the instruments themselves you
want to absorb that away somehow i guess
that's what
that's the task well that's one method
of doing that
you know yeah other methods are let it
shake
and then you have to build it such that
it will withstand those vibrations
oh
[Laughter]
forgive me i hadn't thought about build
the sucker
so that it can shake and bake and then
it doesn't matter
then you don't have to waste weight on
building cushions for it that's
interesting i like that
i like that idea okay cool all right
this is st20ic
says will this take better quality
photos
so are we talking iphone 5 or iphone 12
pro what are we looking at what are we
looking at photo wise
we're indeed looking at the beautiful
mars photos in higher resolution
we're also having a high resolution
cameras on the end of the arm
so that we can get up really close to
the rocks
hit them with x-ray look at the glow
and image that and really understand a
lot about the mineralogy
and the composition before we decide to
drill a hole
and bring back that sample wait is that
that famous
alpha proton x-ray it's similar
yeah it's similar this is called a
pixel and it's designed to
zap the rock with x-rays let it
fluoresce but also
image it also image that okay
so is that an acronym for something
pixel
yeah because i'm going to tell you
something in the name department you
guys are losing
alpha proton alpha proton
uh x-ray x-ray spectrometer
geologists love that that instrument
because it sounds like
it sounds like my tax dollars went to do
something
and you know you gotta you gotta hype it
up jim you gotta hype it up you can't
just be like
so we got this great technology it's
called pixel uh
you know no you gotta hype it up you
know we
can make it sound like a diabolical
weapon on batman
right alpha beta you know okay
aqua do loop something all right so so
this instrument
sits on the end of the arm and fires a
ray gun
at really high intensities
glowing the rock heating it up and
letting it tell us what it what it's
made of
give that man an extra billion dollars
just for that sentence we're going to
call it our
photo phaser spectrum phaser it's our
final phaser
spectrograph like something yeah
just make it sound like something that
would be on batman that's that man's
utility belt
it's not the ray gun on stein you know
it's on kill
it's on vaporize yes vaporize nice
all right chuck we're in lightning round
mode right now so
how many can see how many questions you
can get through and jim you're in sound
bite mode
pretend you're on the evening news and
you we we can only give them one or two
sentences okay
here we go samuel king wants to know
this
tell the truth jim is this one of the
first steps
to terraforming mars could be
and the reason why is we're going to
learn so much about the environment
that will then take that knowledge to
terraform mars
okay foundational knowledge i like that
good sound bite too
get a plus on that sound bite nice okay
chuck give me another
all right seisio seisio
wants to know this how do you guys pick
the right place
to land we want to go to the best place
where we can get samples and that's why
we're going to a delta an ancient
area on mars where water and sediment
is landed on the bottom and created rock
a delta like the mississippi delta
guaranteed to have layers because it's
been sedimented
nice and and the and implicit theories
of course
mars has deltas right this is wow this
is an interesting fact
all right delta's enough for you to pick
one to land on
okay keep going chuck that's why i love
the martian blues
okay so uh selku killman one
says this what will happen to the
other rovers will they just retire and
leave it there as space trash
all rovers and all instruments that are
working on mars we want to keep them
working
keep making new and exciting discoveries
until
they die and they will be there
for us to explore as humans when we land
and in fact you might need those to beam
signals back to earth
the way uh
matt damon mark watney yeah his name
mark watney yeah yeah
yeah so you need those yeah yeah you
need those in case you have to rewire
them
and send signals back to earth of course
duh
okay chuck keep it going a couple more
we've got time for a couple more
all right here we go this is
uh beer games
who says hello will this rover be
responsible for
any preparation for humans
to travel to mars so the answer is
yes because we have an experiment
that brings in the atmosphere and
creates oxygen that we can breathe
you know it's called the oxygenator on
the movie the martian
but we call it moxie on perseverance
once again it sounds a little better i
was going to say once again
you guys got to work on these terms man
come on yeah
yeah and we'll be back to get it
so you so what you're doing is you're
breaking apart the carbon dioxide
molecule
right right okay all right
this is chris cherry if you want chris
cherry says
what is for this mission
your chief and primary goal
and what is something you secretly
hope to discover
we want to search the past from the rock
record to see
if mars could have supported life
and my secret wish is that we find it
a fossil bone sticking out of the rock i
mean what like what do you what do you
what what so we don't creature that
falls out from under a rock no we don't
anticipate
getting fossils but the chemical
composition is just right
for which you know there there's
potential uh
cells or microbial uh
uh indications that uh life could have
survived on mars early on in its history
so jim i'm gonna take host privileges
and just ask the last question here
uh we launched perseverance to mars was
it uh june
was it 2020 what july and
did anyone else launch at around that
time because you know
this is the the months over which earth
and mars are are nicely
configured for just that can we shoot
them down if they beat us
well we have we have the lasers but
they're going to be used on mars
[Music]
every 26 months neil you're right
everything lines up
where we can launch from earth and make
it to mars
as fast as possible but we are not the
only nation
going so the chinese have launched a
mission to mars
with an orbiter and a lander and a rover
all right and in addition to that
united arab emirates has also launched a
mission
that will get into orbit and make
atmospheric measurements and image the
surface
so the road to mars is open and it's
busy
and are we collaborating are we sharing
information with these with everybody
to art i mean you scientists all love
each other so
i mean we do is that is that happening
or is it more like governments
no indeed everyone knows
about the other missions we know when
they're going to launch
we know how they're going to operate you
know for for instance
perseverance is going to be dropped
right
onto the surface you know we're not
going to get into orbit so it's like
hitting a golf ball in new york and
having uh
the ball go in a hole in la you know
it's just one straight
shot the chinese have a different
approach there
they will first get in orbit spend some
time there and then
drop their capsule with their rover down
to the surface at a later time
everybody has different tactics there
are different tactics yeah
this is great and it's a reminder that
science really
at the end of the day knows no national
boundaries because
it is the one true unifying language not
only of us all but
between us and what might be aliens that
we greet one day
because they will surely be using the
same science we are
to get around the house and around the
backyard
and that's great as long as america wins
what's the check american
all right we got to end it there uh jim
green great to have you back on star
talk
and uh if we can reach out to you for
other nasa
activities that'd be great of course
it's always good knowing that you're
there anytime
chuck tweeting at chuck nice comic thank
you yes
yes i am all right uh neil degrasse
tyson you're a personal astrophysicist
as always beating you
[Music]
you